it's weird that people live in new york
city by choice but anyway
yeah i don't think you're not a fan of
new york city bro i left i
left have you been you've spent time in
new york it's yeah jersey and new york
are tattooed on my own i love new york
i love visiting new york city i'll say
isn't it yeah this is the best city i
love it visiting is one thing but
living there there are certain places
people live and i'm like man if you can
get out why are you still there you've
lived in saudi arabia for 19 years
oh my god you'd rather live in saudi
arabia than new york no you guys don't
have a clue
no really a clue really no well
how's it going the fact that you're the
fact that you're stepping in saudi
arabia
you all don't have a clue like how the
fact you're comparing i'm like dude
like shout out to my boys
tell us about saudi arabia what is it
like living there about like living
there like in like an expat community
bro
like you're talking zero crime rate
you're talking
zero taxes you're talking amazing
amenities
fantastic infrastructure incredible
communities fantastic schools
the company you work for paying for your
child's education
up to college level you're talking about
free healthcare
you're talking about fantastic weather
is this specifically in expat
communities you said
yeah so this part okay but a lot of what
i'm talking about is
the whole country saudi arabia has no
taxes period
okay um the infrastructure around the
seas even if you're talking riad jetta
etc
it's excellent they're extraordinarily
low crime rates like you or
you are safer in any saudi city than you
are in any major city in the us
by miles not even not even comparable by
miles
um do you live under the same laws is
there
are they like were the women in your
family uh forced sharia law
which law are you talking about well my
understanding of saudi arabia is that
there
are repressive cultural laws about what
you can wear what you can say what you
can post
you know the there is no liquor there
right it's not
alcohol free yeah alcohol i'm out i'm
out bro alcohol free yeah
if that's a thing if that's a big thing
for you women specifically do they have
to wear the hajib
so the hijab you mean so it depends so
stuff has also all changed so i left
saudi in 2008.
so things have actually changed quite
significantly from what i understand
over the past decade because women can
drive now
everyone can drive now yes it's a big
deal that is because they couldn't drive
2016. there was just a story recently of
women who snuck in to watch a soccer
game and then i think we're stoned to
death though
so in saudi yeah
okay yeah please verify that one because
that sounds sketch
okay but there you gotta admit it sounds
awesome
don't have it easy in saudi arabia look
look you're not the type of you're not
the tourism
bureau of saudi arabia has never been
there but i mean i'm trying to
understand
yeah that's why i'm laughing because i'm
like when did you go right i lived there
for 19 years
so um saudi arabia basically grew up
there i grew up in saudi arabia dude
i wasn't i went to school there until i
was i would have stayed i mean
i went to boarding school from the age
of 11 back in the uk
so i was back and forth between the two
countries from 11 to 20.
um but you know and like where i grew up
so it's why i don't sound british
right because a lot of people i grew up
with were american um i grew up in an
extraordinarily diverse community people
from all over the world most my teachers
were american i was in the american
school system
from preschool up until fifth grade in
fact interesting um and then i switched
over to the british
so saudi is a man on every level it's a
gigantically
misunderstood country in a lot of ways
so obviously as an expat
you have a certain experience which is
if you have you been in dubai i have not
yes okay you've been in dubai so closer
closer to that
than like some it's not saudi arabia is
not iran just so you know it's not
uh and by the way keep this in mind what
he's saying
are you saudi arabian yeah yeah
it's not even close yeah people can
people conflate them yeah but but kai
can you pull out what i just sent you 10
questions about expat life in saudi
arabia answer this one website
okay interesting and uh one of one of
the things that if you can pull that up
kai yeah
uh it's actually pretty interesting uh
what it talks about how women
flirt with men like dating life in saudi
arabia go all the way down so one thing
for gerard it was in iran
it was in iran okay keep going down
conflate them okay accept
pers click accept okay keep going down
what's that going to keep going keep
going keep going keep going keep going
keep going keep going family values okay
keep going
keep going a little lower it's about to
come up here
lower a little lower right there they
didn't get a kid first dates must be
low-key affairs if you live in the same
compound or can let them into yours
you will likely spend your first date at
the movies or the compounds restaurant
and most likely society rules don't
apply within a compound this is great
relaxed option for a couple some
restaurants and big cities also offer
private cabins and are
lacks about letting genders mix within
their establishment asking around your
expat circles is a good way to discover
date spots okay so extremely
conservative many
dating a local many young saudis now
flirt more openly on apps such as
facebook tinder snapchat and
and who share however women in
particular may still shy away from
sending photos over messaging apps for
fear of family or percussion snapchat is
popular
and as a woman you may well be asked
uh a moment in snapchat literally
snapchat possible you may also be
so dating is it the goal of the lord kai
go little lord to see what else can
saudis marry foreigners over seven
hundred thousand saudi women
ten percent of all married saudi women
are also americans our foreign doesn't
know
no corresponding figures are available
for saudi men married to non-national
so if it's a saudi spouse you're looking
for there is hope
arranged marriages marriages are still
often arranged between conservative
families
lgbt relations homosexuality transgender
individuals moving to saudi arabia
should be aware that it is illegal for
men
to act and dress like women and vice
versa homosexuality activity is also
against the law
and attracts the death penalty
find it easier to meet and socialize
with potential partners but they say
what it's like to work inside so only
muslims can
marry in saudi arabia therefore expat
couples of other faiths need to wait
outside well
are you are you are you muslim no i'm
christian christian okay
yeah so why did you deliberately why did
you leave
uh you retire at 60 there so my dad
reached 60
and the company he worked for you retire
at 60. and so
by the way if you do the math if you do
the math so this whole thing about well
you why can't why don't they need taxes
why don't they tax anybody oil money
okay they've got the national it's like
dubai doesn't tax you right and
unemployment is nothing
but save data and tax tax corporations
that money goes to the corporations
what's the big deal if corporations pay
for kids college education nothing we
can afford it
what's the big deal if corporations pay
for your health insurance nothing they
can afford it
what's the big deal you know what
companies can do if they didn't pay
taxes
saudi aramco one of the biggest two and
a half trillion dollar company in the
world yeah so
that's uh so so so i'll explain so with
the expat thing so saudi aramco so when
i grew up there this is you know in the
you know from the 80s to the 90s early
thousands
uh so a company like saudi aramco they
basically have
their own towns so everyone where i
lived worked the same company
and they have like four or five of those
like
dotted around so um they're called camps
which i think was was mentioned
i mentioned that that's a throwback to
the industrial revolution yeah so
so it's weird i mean even me being in
the uk i mean it was weird when i went
to houston and even parts of
miami etc it's weird because it looks
like this place
looks more like saudi than it looks like
england
right so when i was in houston i was
like whoa it looks like saudi because of
the refineries and all that or because
the company just
everything the way everything is laid
out yeah it's beautiful if you pull up
saudi
arabia and put up pictures the buildings
the the structures are beautiful
how old were you when you left uh saudi
20 20 did you have a girlfriend
uh in the uk yeah but in
saudi did you have a girlfriend there
not in saudi no not inside so i went to
boarding school from 11.
so i was in boarding school and then in
university from 11 to 20 in the uk
so the first time you had a girlfriend
how old were you 15
15. yeah but that was in saudi uh no
this was in england
in boarding school in boarding school in
england yeah how much time
so you were literally going back back
and forth between the two countries so
you were going to boarding school yeah
so
so during terms so during term time i'm
in england
and then during the vacations i'm back
how many months here are you in saudi
uh during that period yeah uh how much
how much vacation time is there i know
four or five months four or five months
a year you're in saudi the rest of the
time you're in boarding school and you
can
yeah what is that i believe it's called
hogwarts in the uk
he's a he's an oil they did they do film
harry potter and partially in my
university of course is that right yeah
in oxford no way yeah
um i think what is it uh christchurch
college i think
you went to oxford yeah how was how was
oxford oxford was cool man it was cool
is it what is is it the harvard of you
know is it
is the best yeah sell us on oxford sell
us an oxford well it's
the oldest university in the world um i
i hate uh first absolutely hate ivy
league elites though but please go on
that's all right i like you up until now
it's not ivy league it's not ivy league
that's not a thing in the uk um yeah i
mean oxford and cambridge are
you know for decades have been the best
if not centuries
been two of the best universities in the
entire world certainly the top two in
the uk
i studied computer science which was i
didn't love my subject
i didn't love my subject but oxford
itself is a city have you ever been to
oxford no the city is beautiful
absolutely beautiful city the
architecture is
mind-blowing incredible how far is it
from london is it is it uh only an hour
and a half oh okay
yeah about 90 miles or something like
that um so is it a party town with
students because the school is there
there's two universities so there's
oxford
and then there's oxford brooks um so
there it's it's quite a student-oriented
place
it's quite a student-oriented place but
it's it's oxford's a fantastic city it's
one of my
probably top five cities in the uk and
i've been to all of them
um but yeah it's a great place obviously
you know hyper academic
incredibly you're surrounded by
incredibly smart people all the time
which means you're always having
great conversations and it's it's good
you know when you're surrounded by
people who inspire you in some way shape
or form there's a lot of
value in that and when you're somewhere
with so much history and literally i
mean i think my college in oxford was
built in the 1200s wow um didn't c.s
lewis go to oxford was c.s lewis
he went to oxford he taught at oxford
i'm not sure yeah i'm not certain
there's a there's a movie about c.s
lewis his story is an and i think he
used to go
can you pull up c.s lewis profile is
that the rhodes scholars is that oxford
uh yeah yeah oxford has rhodes scholars
so you get it
so oxford is more like a boston yeah he
went to oxford
he's uh
have you seen his movie put c.s lewis
movie you ever seen this movie i haven't
oh my gosh i highly recommend anybody i
can watch it it's not a
story of a not or not those movies the
story uh
a life story movie i typed that there's
a movie that you know who plays it
uh anthony hopkins plays it there you go
shadowlands
if you've never seen this movie it is
absolutely fascinating how interesting
of a human being this guy was
from going and being an atheist to
writing mere christianity to divorce
letters i think he wrote divorce letter
screw tape letters
uh uh you know maybe one of the greatest
authors of all time on the stuff that he
wrote and
he would go to oxford and they would
debate to hear those debates that he
would have with all these other
scholars and professors and educators
you know the the part about
was it a big debate type of school were
you guys always was it a debate format
is that how you guys learned uh no
not like for typical not for typical
learning but there's the oxford union
which you may have heard of where they
they bring in speakers and
they have uh you know there's debate
societies and stuff like that
um were you ever a part of it or no
because no i was never personally a part
of it i wasn't personally a part of it i
was kind of
i can see you doing good at that like
yeah sincerely i can see you actually
doing good at that that's how you debate
yeah did uh did your philosophy did your
did your kind of libertarian philosophy
originate there in oxford has that come
later in life because
i'm wondering here between the saudi
upbringing it could be my my
my misunderstanding of saudi culture
sure and in oxford it would seem that
that your uh your belief system
although at least as it's presented
through social media seems to kind of be
uh in it
it doesn't converge with with what your
upbringing should be right
is that you seem to have come from a
very controlled environment and now
you seem to promote a lot of personal
freedom i didn't come from a
soup i didn't come from a super
controlled environment not in my
household nor
in you know so so saudi's interesting
because you know
here's something that's interesting to
know is that you know what people call
like the left-right political spectrum
doesn't apply globally well it doesn't
even apply anymore
yeah but 18th century french yeah but
you know if you talk to people in most
of europe or
in right in us you know it's always the
left and the right and you know
democrats republicans we were talking
about this earlier etc right so
so like i said somewhere like saudi it's
ultra conservative on certain things
sort of in the middle on certain things
and actually sort of you know
very it's a combination of all first of
all
it's a monarchy right so there there are
no kingdoms
yeah there's no political parties what's
the liberal part of saudi arabia
this is what i mean right there's no
there's no wings like there's no not
even wings so what are they
liberal on okay so what i mean is so
okay look at the things some people in
the
u.s what do you what do u.s progressives
want they want free health care
saudi has that they want free schooling
saudi has that they even want some of
them
the extreme the far lefties want free
university
saudi arabia okay guys right what do
libertarians want same issues
libertarians want no taxes because
taxation is theft
saudi has that right why are you why are
you living in uk why don't you go live
there
um i don't re i've as far as i'm
concerned i've left the uk
oh so you're now what you're i don't
know i'm a global
global nomad after the past year and a
half i was like you know what i'm done
with it are you a globalist
i'm not a globalization you're living
anywhere and everywhere
i don't know i'm in the u.s for the next
three months um beyond that we
we shall see i mean i did i feel
such this is what you and i always have
our heated discussions about dude you
don't know what it's like to have
corrupt politicians steal your home from
you they steal your home
and then you have to then adjust because
if you don't adjust then you're going to
become a criminal and
that's you know so they they've
literally i'm sure you didn't want to
leave your home but they've made it an
untenable situation man
the uk is a yeah it's i feel sad like i
was i was going to end up leaving the uk
anyway because
my audience in the us is much bigger you
know more opportunities here etc so
you know i could well end up living in
florida texas et cetera once i get my
visa
um but you know as for me right now
unfortunately i'm location independent
with my business and everything i do so
i don't i'm not tied to any particular
city
or country um which is wonderful
so you know as far as i'm concerned i'm
kind of flexible right now but
i'm very disillusioned with the uk now
which makes me sad because i do love the
country
are you leaning towards anywhere are you
leaning towards where you want to live
or
not if it's in the u.s probably florida
texas or tennessee
outside the u.s um you know i'm a big
fan of central and eastern europe i like
czech republic hungary poland romania
places like that
um thoughts on norway by the way
thoughts on norway
i've never been there oh so you gotta go
i haven't been to norway myself
singapore singapore i don't know i've
i've heard that singapore's been
terrible throughout all this um
singapore is another weird one because
it's
very authoritarian um but it's also very
free market
yeah it's it's it's weird you know it's
a it's another one i think sort of like
interview that lived in singapore uh the
the crypto billionaire that bought
people's every day is for six and a half
minutes yeah
yeah and he swears by singapore he
swears by what it's like to live in
singapore yeah singapore
so what do you consider home at this
point
um hotel rooms any hotel room yeah yeah
i mean look in terms of
where i'm from is always a weird
question because i'm literally a british
nigerian who grew up in saudi arabia
and went to an american school and does
not have a british accent
yeah it sounds like america yeah exactly
and has quite a lot of
you know american values like i always
get told man zubi are more american than
most americans right um and
my you know i'm i don't like any
political party but i'm i'm more of a
republican than i am a
tory right in terms of my actual views
on stuff
and that's pretty rare in the uk and i
think that's for me not growing up there
living in saudi arabia so
with me you know i mean like there's
there's pro one thing i've really
learned you know i've traveled to
about 36 countries and had heavy
exposure to all these different cultures
we've mentioned
and with me one thing i've really
learned is you know there's pros and
cons to
all different cultures and political
systems and ways of doing things it's
not just
one thing i think a lot in the west is
people kind of have this okay this is
the one way
of doing things this is how we do it and
everything we do is the best way of
doing it
and i'm like no some things are right
there's lots of stuff movie america's
number one but yeah
we are number one yeah well people say
that but then they haven't often been
anywhere else right but daniel tasha the
thing is like
people hate us because we keep saying
we're number one the terrorists don't
like it just
just say we're top ten top ten yeah yeah
they're top ten all right that's fine
pb question for you you you kind of have
a similar
story i mean you've been all over the
world you've traveled what do you
consider a home
oh listen it's born in iran made in
america oh i've heard that
born in iran made in america it's that
simple for me i've been all over the
world
when you're in the military you go
everywhere when you're you know
iran you're coming up you live at a
refugee camp germany you see it
traveled to i don't know 50 countries
you know with
all the traveling we've done but uh
nothing comes close to this
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye